so you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
perfect what's up guys i am thomas
dobasil whatever you want to call me
this is dope as usual podcast i'm here
with my co-host marty o'neil what's up
guys i was very low energy one
that's smooth today it's smooth okay all
right so i feel kind of amped up for
some reason guys this is the doppler
usually podcast i'm here with marty i'm
thomas whatever you want to call we're
here to talk about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between today we have a special guest
hasn't been here since season one it's
been a while this is ratchet tone
ratchet man oh my god whatever you want
to call this fool what are your names do
you go by baby sinclair uh baby sinclair
pollo rachmann rachiton almara
i don't know that sounds like authentic
accent you have there oh it's just one
of the things it's like my tag that i
use
this is it's not real words okay and i'm
just gonna get spanish
all right so it's been a while the last
time you came the next day you're going
on tour oh yeah that's right that's the
last time you were here right the danny
duncan tour yes so let me start off
right now real quick uh in case you are
a new fan
this is one of my homies i've been
chilling with this fool for a very long
time i met you
at diamond warehouse
you were doing all the diamond stuff yep
then it moved on to now you're doing
music and i just want to catch you i'm
gonna go over your whole story yeah okay
so
it's been a long time probably a lot of
new fans
you know what we should do i met this
fool at the diamond warehouse he used to
work for diamond that's how he if you
follow me for a long time that's how i
was getting the the diamonds one of a
hundred beetle shoe for my birthday
these people got it for me it was
i still have it they're dirty but yeah
yeah still
beautiful it was like a yellow submarine
called yellowstone
like 50 anniversary some [ __ ] like that
yeah it was cool and then you started
doing music well we started chilling a
lot you started doing music yeah
you do a lot we were just talking about
the other day
a kind of like a professional doc
connector oh when you were doing
all the diamond stuff is how you got
linked with with all the artists yeah
mainly right yeah around that time and
being from hollywood being around here
yeah kind of gets in it kind of like
goes hand in hand if you're not just
yeah i was in the skateboarding world so
it's kind of hand-to-hand
skateboarding
fashion
yeah you don't meet a lot of people that
grew up their whole lives i went high to
hollywood
what time were you at like three seconds
so uh catch us up last time you were
here the next day or the next two days
later you're going on tour yeah how the
first couple tours i get it uh
you probably drank too much even though
danny duncan is completely sober this
fool got drunk
because i mean it was one it's like one
of those like you go to like let's say a
venue right and then they're like oh the
main act doesn't drink they're like what
doesn't drink how about about the the
crew or how about the the rest of the
crew you're like oh he does so they
point at me or kiwan or something like
they're like they smoke and drink so i
was like yeah go party with them they're
like all right so then we'll just go and
then the owner would give us mad drinks
and we get
open bar to the point where sometimes we
would be plastered we're like [ __ ]
just go back there serve our drinks the
guy's lagging it but
yeah i would get shit-faced and stuff
but this time around
i was smarter but
dumber i guess i was doing other dumb
[ __ ] like you you put yourself in harms
way more yeah yeah i was jumping like
stage diving in like a pile hold up
explain it explain it who did you try to
stab dodge on to a bunch of kids
what kind of kids were they big kids
football players no no no so so danny
yeah daddy's demographic is like all all
over the place kids like little skinny
puny kids
there's like families there well kids
that aren't full grown men yeah
yeah they're skinny kids still but don't
get me wrong though like another to
another stops on the tour some of these
kids were wild like more crazier than
the other city so they could actually
hold me like in chicago they were
holding me in chicago and they were
going crazy like again throw them again
and i was like chicago you lit you know
say because they hold me you're talking
about full trust fall you're just
walking up
there's a video not even not even my
friends
it was not even a trust fall it was more
like belly
like straight wrestling move like
pick me up
how many people does it take to catch
ratchet at least four four people okay
that's no no no no four hold big to men
grown man security guard dudes eight
kids but
yeah
it was just like a like you know when
you like domino effect like
yeah it was like that and then i just
hear people laughing kids recording and
laughing
and then like
i had a like a big panda express [ __ ]
play before so i'm running backstage and
i'm like
hyperventilating about to throw up this
food and then danny runs back he's like
where's my dj like what is going on he
goes back there and he sees me like
you're good you're good i was like let's
go so i literally just kind of try to
force puke myself
but i ran back and everything was cool
but yeah it was it was they died
um i succeeded and felt like twice
probably but like i succeeded three
times so it was cool how i found out
about stuff he was on tours people kept
dming me stuff that danny duncan was
posting like yo get your homie i got
like
2 000 tags on twitter of them putting
candies in your mouth and you and you
all in your sleep oh yeah so that that
was actually like that was after like a
week after like a week after the tour he
was like yo let's just go random stuff
he was just like i want everybody back
like it feels weird because it was like
around kobe just opened so danny was
like yo fly to florida man i'll fly you
to florida we need to get more clips and
all that so i was like all right i'm
going to florida but mind you this we
took a red eye we didn't sleep so west
coast times when you get there you get
there like prime
8 pm you know 9 8 a.m in the morning
and there they pick you up
somehow he [ __ ] told us
yeah we're gonna fly you to to where
he's from right because you checked the
time didn't you um so no because i want
so then so then um
he ended up sending us to
i think it was tampa or somewhere yeah
tampa because tampa and pro like
skateboarding stuff
i guess it was around that weekend and
he was sponsoring a skater over there so
he was like yo just meet me there so he
rerouted our flight to go there so we
were all early just
waking up the skater like at seven in
the morning where he has a skate
competition like at noon and i felt bad
because i was like he has to skate like
you know like yes and like whatever we
got there and then danny comes and
as soon as i walk into the to like tampa
and pro i started seeing all my homies
like pro skaters like chazz
everybody like
kelly and everybody's like yo what the
[ __ ] are you doing here and i was like
yo what up
not knowing i was gonna see friends that
i you know met a diamond and they're
like what the hell bro
this is a good feeling to see like that
the skateboard world they're all like
showing mad love to danny too because he
came from that world too so it's cool it
was cool yeah yeah he used to actually
stretch every skater kind of weird but
he was physical therapy yeah he was a
physical therapist yeah
he used to come to stretch me
no no no but he used to like physical
therapist yeah he used to be like yo uh
this is how you stretch this is what you
got to do like before like uh x games
and stuff you used to do it to like pros
and that's how you got in there too yeah
and
pretty much um out he just started doing
youtube going wild and then every time
he'll like i see him i'm like bro you
gonna go crazy because he's a wild
person you know in general like and he
don't do drugs he ever feared for your
life in any any situation
while doing stuff with this fool or
what's the time you're like i might
break my back
um just the motorcycle jumps and stuff
when you feel like
well that was my because i really want
to learn how to wheelie i still want to
learn how to really so i'm still going
to go try it but
maybe like when he was doing like those
jumps through the fire ring of fire and
like those like dude i was
i was holding for my life like ah
you know but i was screaming of
excitement but also scared you know what
i'm saying like yeah
but yeah well you were on the back i was
in the tv not an atv in the side they're
flying through jumps yeah
i was um
pre the ring pre-ring they put the ring
on fire and then they're like who's
getting on i was like i'm not getting on
that [ __ ] i'll do the
other ramp and [ __ ]
13 oh yeah we're here yeah but it was
one of those but you know what i'm
saying
because he has this wild energy like
does he mind if you guys are all drunk
and wild and [ __ ] or does he like kind
of like not mind that no he he doesn't
care bro i mean how long is that like if
you are functional and you're not like
yeah dumb and sloppy around him then
ready pretty cool it's from pk bros i
did i went to a tour the other day yeah
keef and hash covered blunts
there you go
i'm gonna smoke a joint because i'd have
got a crazy ass blunt for after this
joint i got some i got some other [ __ ]
over here they're hemp lens by the way
non-tobacco
yeah you hold on to that for a second
all right give me a flavor can you give
me that more [ __ ] ash tracer thank
you youtube leave me alone just let us
know yeah leave me alone hey
no it's crazy because um other ashtray
is over there right fun little fact fun
little fact that i used to work for
johnny shipes remember yeah and
was one of the guys that was just
remember i was coming at that time and
look at him now yeah
i'm sorry yeah i was doing the uh i did
the smoker's club tour i hosted it yeah
right before
you started working there or at was it
after no i was working there already
very new yeah and i remember we took the
uber together got us uber over there so
where to to the festival i forgot what
was the festival oh smoke is fast
yeah that was like a five-hour ordeal i
just and then we were
i was like that's when i i seen jit
perform for the first time we were oh
jed yeah we hit the sick ass jacket and
then we saw
um i saw earl sweatshirt perform i was
like damn dude black boy jb was kind of
new he was yes yes there was a bunch of
big artists and that's the first time i
saw flatbush zombies perform live yeah
those fools control the entire crowd
yeah it was shocking marty to see like 3
000 people know every [ __ ] word
anything they said it was
they put on a show like hip-hop they put
on a [ __ ] show that was good it's
good to see like
uh hip-hop actually right now hip-hop's
coming back bro
like hip-hop is coming back like that
grimy dirty like new york like that
basement sound i think it's coming back
you know i mean i feel like
grisel does doing a really good job with
that you know [ __ ] yeah choosing beats
west side gun quarterback [ __ ] shout
out to my guys daily gems though they'll
be recording all the videos and all that
stuff guys like in new york videos yeah
yeah yeah those are my guys like the
animation yeah yeah
all right let's get back on track all
right you're back from uh tour
right you're back on tour
and currently for everyone i mean
we touched on a little bit right about
the music
last time yeah yeah they know i make
music i guess slightly right we didn't
really go too crazy into it though you
went to texas to start working on [ __ ]
recently right yeah yeah so tell me
about that uh i went to texas um i have
uh
friends mutual friends that are like
you know
for example one of my friends dusty he
also produces and um
he uh
he was a kombi kings dj and that's like
selena's brother's band uh the kumbi
kings
so then uh my other friend zeus he's
from san antonio he's like yeah i'll be
working with a few people here and there
like from the family dino's family like
i know
chris and like that's selena's husband
and then selena's husband's just
chilling with us we're over here working
on music and today i eat pepperoni pizza
and hot sauce
[Music]
but you know
that's all i remember
and it's one of those crazy things that
growing up i wanted to be him you know
what i'm saying like
who didn't want to i oh i mean i still
have long hair but
like yo he was the rock star dude he had
the most beautiful woman in the world so
i was like yo and i was in love with her
dude i was probably one of those i mean
yeah those kids that cried for selena
when she died you know they're like when
was that like 95 85 or 4 or something
like that and then
yeah yeah but um
pre space jam first just you know it's
just being in an environment like with
these people like them like that i
looked up to and then now i'm just
chilling partying with them seeing them
in san antonio they get to see my
creative side i make music and produce
some of the stuff really drunk the
spanish stuff that i play to you know
that was amazing i love how you're
fusing these different genres together
you're so unique yeah so now i'm just
adding kind of like the cumbia sound
with the trap sound and like mixing it
also like atl flavor because i got fk
first to back me up with that so it's
like let's go i just do all the i guess
either little loops or whatever and then
now i'm just passing it to
uh first or i have a producer another
guy ace i just tell him hey maybe we
should do it like this too this this and
he can make it come alive and that's
that's what i like going to san antonio
because there's a lot of creative people
in san antonio and like they have that
cumbia sound because it comes from
that
you know kombi kings they're like the
the gods of that you know like yeah and
does that translate to um
yeah yeah yeah
you know and that accordion stuff that i
was playing yeah yeah just blending that
in with trap is kind of crazy yeah cause
that's like international music yeah
it's a texas style too you know what i'm
saying i'm not gonna lie like texas has
that drill like that uh how can i say
chop the screwed texas like for example
i also work with uh abraham's son and he
produces a principe and
he made some records with me and he does
chopped and screwed cumbias and that's
uh selena's brother's
what
nephew i think uh no selena's brother's
son so neptune yeah so selena's nephew
and the crazy thing is that i probably
said this before but when he was in l.a
he was like yeah i want to eat some
papoosas i'm sorry dorian's house i'm
gonna take you to eat papooses i took
empanadas it's like a no think of a
tortilla flat tortilla but with like
meat and cheese and yeah yeah yeah but
like handmade all right so i took him to
hippopota in hollywood
and
selena actually ate there too before had
signed everything like thank you
restaurant and i was like damn it was
meant to be it was meant for you didn't
even realize that i know that she went
there and then i'm like yo
that's your aunt right there she was
here he was like what it was crazy yeah
it was crazy i was like damn that's
crazy but yeah that's that's recently
i'm gonna wrap up this cumbia album go
back to san antonio like in two weeks
wrap it up
and get it ready for the world because
it's i think it's almost ready you heard
some of this stuff and i feel like how
many tracks are you going uh it's my i'm
to be honest i was in the label and i
didn't drop my first album so it's gonna
be my first first first first first
first album ever i guess you would say
but i'm just gonna put five tracks on it
mm-hmm maybe i put features no maybe no
features i don't know but right now it's
just me
what's the all right someone's out there
right now someone's in
indiana yeah full makes like enough
money to pay rent but wants to make
music
what's he supposed to do keep making
music no i mean what's he supposed to do
in terms of like trying to get studios
to go get a certain program a mic
recorded himself so so this is one of
the things that i've learned of making
music you can make music anywhere you do
not need a studio you just need to write
little
two things it's called the interface and
a microphone if you have that and
there's three things yeah three things
computer interface microphone that's all
you need
but
technology is so crazy bro you could
there's people killing it in garageband
in ipads cell phones there's no reason
for star wars on a cell phone like you
guys that you were making i was
astonished when you said you sampled the
sounds off your cell phone should sound
so crisp in the speakers you can do so
much now bro there's not an excuse
there's free apps there's there's
everything you know and like if you
don't know how to upload your music all
you got to do is look for toon chord
distro kid
united master you upload your song
distro kid united master yeah those are
the ones if you want to start
independently next next thing you know
you get ten dollars 20 bucks that's how
you get your music on apple youtube yeah
spotify all of it they'll send it all to
all platforms all you got to do is
upload it right correctly make sure you
if you worked with another artist split
the the thing in half
like you know what i'm saying make sure
your business comes correct because
that's at the end of the day like
if the song blows up and the uh the
producer didn't get no credits no
royalties or nothing
the guy's gonna feel played he's gonna
i'm gonna take that song down like or
something you know what i'm saying it
always happens it's music it's tricky
and it's business too at the end of the
day so it's like make sure if you're an
artist learn your business for sure
usually it's either you're getting a big
check up front and you're kind of
releasing your rights to that or you're
locked in
into the perpetrator yeah
i mean i've been paid so look for
example i've been paid without saying
everything tell about how your first day
worked out oh well my first deal was
different my my first deal was a
blessing one first in history one in
history i was in front of the [ __ ] vr
spot when you [ __ ] called me yeah
like i when i got my record deal it was
kind of like different and crazy because
i got signed kind of like
by by just hearing it you know like i
guess they were shopping for someone
else or something
and they happened to hear my song in
versus computer while he was just
scrolling through music showing them and
they were like wait wait what is that
you know and then at the time it was
like the soundcloud days was really
popular but i had made some soundcloud
style type of music but in spanish he's
like yo i don't understand a word you're
saying bro but
this song right here what the that's
exactly what i said i don't know what
you're saying but i like yeah and at the
time i wasn't even taking it serious
because i was doing all the connecting
the dots i was helping other people like
21 and like a lot of people trying to
link dots with like diamond and do this
collapse with this
or lakai needed oh huff whatever like
anything i was just trying to get up
there you know like yo whatever i can do
set parties up you know i know these
rappers you want to throw a party let's
do it and then i'll hit up ham on
everything link those dots and do a
crazy party you know
so yeah i i just i don't know
you're like
i can't really think anybody else is
such a great example of like
what i always preach about what skills
you need to be successful and it's to be
able to connect dots between people yeah
and to have a bunch of different
creative skills like you're not just a
rapper or a scent you get into so many
different facets so i kind of it's kind
of when they ask me that question what
do you do i can't really i can't really
explain it to someone i can't tell
somebody i just say i'm an artist
because at the end of the day anything i
do is art you know what i'm saying music
photography or whatever it is you know i
do it all and it's like and you help
other people helping me out yeah i
helped i helped a lot of people like
there's a lot of people i helped but
they might not give me my flowers or
whatever but i don't care when you can
add value to like high-powered people or
just people in the industry that's how
you keep going like you're never gonna
you keep evolving and getting in a
different ship because of who you know
and how you can like add value under
their differences yeah yeah yeah of
course it's something you preach all the
fun yeah yeah i mean like it's kind of
like one of those things where like just
know
know your
place in the rock yeah yeah yeah on your
role
yeah yeah recognize what that role is
play
sometimes even just you become just okay
let's say for example
i go to the studio i don't tell nobody
i'm a producer i don't tell nobody i'm a
producer but then i produce something on
the side low key and then they hear
they're like
what the [ __ ] was that dude like you
produce they they're like wait wait what
yeah i'm like dude i don't watch it i do
it i do it i do it all i do it all like
[ __ ] they look at you different verses
if you were like i'm a producer i'm
struggling look at my [ __ ] look at my
[ __ ] look at my [ __ ] yeah yeah i don't
think i always say i know a lot of
artists i know a lot of people trying to
be artists i get it being too [ __ ]
eager and being overly overly not like
marty coming up and [ __ ] wrapping
your face different talking about fools
like you know what i'm talking about
yeah it could turn a [ __ ] off i
guess sounds cool yeah can't be around
you bro yeah you gotta get the [ __ ] out
of you you gotta
don't be the guy that go everybody goes
oh don't bring this [ __ ] over
here you gotta be a chief first yeah
thank you
first well yeah well i'm pleased
obviously like every studio you go to is
different rules different people like
bro it's like you have to be
i don't know mutual i guess like i i
don't really care no more like i've been
around so many people it's just like i'm
just there you know and then people are
like yo
ratchet man is sick because they know me
by ratchet man i don't call me ratchet
so that ratchet man that fool's crazy
like he's sick but you know i just
listen like yeah yeah
just yeah do my thing i love that you're
not it's so it's so smart to be that way
yeah yeah like you don't got to be all
up in everybody's face shoving it down
their throat like this is me this is
what i do you can't it's it's smarter to
just be quiet and like you're saying let
them just kind of realize yeah and like
damn he
this motherfucker's a switchblade yeah
he he's doing this he's doing that he's
playing guitar he's doing this he wait
what like it's harmony knife yeah he's
he's over here
putting pedals together like
sounds and you know like
bro we just went to the desert and
recorded like crazy music bro i popped
molly you know i haven't done molly in a
while so
and he
there's every drug you could think of
except for like heroin and [ __ ] like
that but like you know the the good
drugs you know like
lsd schroeder
yeah the creative ones so i was like
[ __ ] it i'll take some money everybody's
doing [ __ ] music we're all in the
desert and [ __ ] i feel like the doors
riders are [ __ ] going crazy and [ __ ]
but it was amazing bro we did like 30
songs like
produce i i
[ __ ] jesus
bro we didn't sleep we didn't sleep for
like what three four days just going so
we we were tweaking the other day right
we started [ __ ] making music
we
usually start what
2 p.m right
but we would go to like nine
take three hour nap wake up
and do it again like
literally there was no sleep and then
sometimes the engineer would be like i
can't sleep because the sun is booming
like you know what i'm saying some
summer some people had to sleep in the
living room because there's not enough
rooms or whatever but it's like it was
amazing bro did the molly actually help
or do you like come to the next day and
be like what the [ __ ] was this
trash i didn't take i didn't i didn't i
didn't it was in a liquid form so i was
just taking sips because i didn't know
all right yes of course i got high and i
[ __ ] stayed up all [ __ ] night
making music but
i'm just saying like i felt amazing i
didn't take enough to like trip the [ __ ]
out i took enough oh
because you were saying that i was
sipping it and every time i felt like
it's kind of cool i guess yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
no we were microdosing everything we
were like we didn't go there to get
[ __ ] up and be like oh can you [ __ ]
perform or play guitar no no no that
would be hard at that point stay your
ass at home bro we're not here for that
you know we're here thumbnail of this
can you please get it we're almost
yeah yeah it is just one of those things
where it like was there a project at
hand that you guys knew like okay i need
to walk away from this week with an
album or was it just like we're just
going to make music no it was one of
those things really like yo it's kind of
like
what is it there's a word for that when
they like
just get like let's say a beach house
and they're like yo so i need oh oh oh
oh think tank yeah
yeah yeah it's one of those and like
just i need my main hitters that are
creative and different
not even trap like we have a hawaiian
guy that he's from hawaii he plays
amazing guitar tour around playing
guitar like and he me and him every time
we play we can synchronize because we i
play dark knows he plays happy stuff so
now we're synchronizing with my dark
style and his kind of like hawaiian
happy style it's like it sounds amazing
bro because he can like tune in what i
can you know i'm saying like we can buy
yeah yeah without so then he has
five other guys like that that do
different types of stuff this guy does
lo-fi this guy does old boom boom
keyboards and then he has his main
engineer and then you got first the
master mama ball like going
you you no wait hold up hold on
yeah you know what i'm saying and and
then he'll go in there and put his drums
in the npc and at his let's take down
some of his credits real quick yeah i
was about to say i don't think they know
who [ __ ] first is all right so
you said first a bunch of times all
right first first first is fki first is
uh my friend uh he produced uh white
iverson for post malone he discovered
post malone he produced travis porter
hey ladies he
produced for ariana grande iggy azalea
migo a lot of every guy you can think of
uh two chains like the songs you
probably heard them and you just didn't
know that was my friend that made him
you know there was for example two days
ago
uh
he had showed me a video oh that one
so he showed me a video he's like yo i
was on tour with post when it was their
first like big tour that went into
europe and my guy my friend smitty was
sleeping and uh
first was um making a beat i'll flash it
up on the screen yeah yeah first was
making a beat so when first was making
the beat it was in front of like the
roman coliseum
and he's in rome yeah in rome in rome so
his view was like the colosseum he's
making a beat going crazy you know and
smitty recorded that he was like
this [ __ ] [ __ ] just waking me up
with this loud ass beating [ __ ] you know
and it's the sports one right it's the
sports [ __ ] theme song that plays in
every arena that i think is little john
let's go or some [ __ ] yeah is this it's
pretty [ __ ] awesome that you're
staring at that
[Music]
[Music]
he just summons us
through some [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying it's a different level to be able
to go yeah
like crazy and do all this crazy when
you're making beats you're literally
just pulling sounds like out of the air
like just
i don't know how to do this [ __ ] but
yeah it was one of those and sit there
and just make a beat is insane to me
yeah real quick we've been talking about
a lot of music i kid it would love it
just in case there's some [ __ ]
pothead ass fool that they go i don't
know what you guys are talking about
we're gonna keep we're gonna keep going
back i have the notes in my head okay
there's no notes up on the thing no i'm
saying
this [ __ ] i'm letting you guys know
right now yeah okay after this
conversation i have one question that's
gonna probably spark a story okay
can i can i i'm sorry don't i mean keep
we're gonna keep talking about first
yeah he did his coliseum thing and you
guys heard it everywhere sorry i just
want to say it before i forget it
[ __ ] high and i've been repeating it
in my head for like
30 to 40 seconds right now so don't
forget don't forget so yeah so pretty
much so sorry me
i guess you know like the more i knew
him the more i started like getting to
know him i started finding out wait he
did watch out little [ __ ] or he did
this he did hey now ladies yeah
i'm like yo i've been hearing that song
since i was a kid like yeah [ __ ] yeah
you know what i'm saying like
and that was my friend made that [ __ ] in
atlanta he was yeah you guys made a lot
of music together yeah we me we actually
have a lot of songs together and uh
we i've been
i've been on my producer grind lately
because of him he kind of expired me
gave me a new program he's like yo trust
me i made all my sand
new hat yeah new hat atlanta
new new program new atlanta hat he's a
hugo bro
get in and zone
get in the zone
that's how he talks too nah nah and then
so yeah so i lately i just been on on
some beast mode [ __ ] and like
nothing's gonna stop me man i'm going at
it every day till six in the morning
until i get tired go to sleep wake up
i'm back at it again you know pretty
much live in the studio now i'm becoming
studio junkie that's cool yeah it's
amazing yeah i love it
you ready
time we have i'm gonna say
41 34. [ __ ]
what's the last time you punch somebody
in the face
whoa
that's my question because i think
that's a different route than music
isn't enough because i know that i wanna
where was that i want people because i'm
in the live chat right now literally me
typing right now in the live chat oh so
i know i want to guide people like yo
it's a lot of music talk like i know
like likes like wait wait wait like when
is the last time you full force
punch somebody in the face i didn't want
to hit this and hit me in the teeth
that's why i punched all dumb in case
you were wondering i know how to punch
well
around it
i i mean i don't really okay i don't
really recall no no no i do i do i don't
remember my first birthday but the thing
is uh all right i'll i'll talk about it
no no no no no no no no punch somebody
in the face over altercation or anger
not because mosh pits no no no no no no
no no no no people punch each other
people punch him
no no um all right so
um you're guilty or something you did
something bad now i can see you i know
you well okay okay okay okay so
i helped
all right all right so i i was in a
party in adults only on sunset in la
brea and me and a bunch of friends like
we were
pretty much chilling outside we were
like [ __ ] we're all leaving and [ __ ]
we're going to after party
um some guy with a big chain [ __ ]
trying to
chain like like he had a big-ass chain
he was like russian i don't know what he
was oh like like a fashion
like baller i thought you meant like a
chain like no no no no no like he had
like a
chain you know what i'm saying
and he
somehow i don't know what happened he
triggered where he like hit one of like
my homies girl or whatever he like
told her like get the [ __ ] out [ __ ] and
like
or something and then she's like oh you
hit me so the first thing we all were
like
get that fool you know what i'm saying
he was a big giant russian guy yeah big
twisty ball too yeah of course he was
wearing no sunglasses and a tight shirt
he had a wife beater and a big chain so
we were like oh this guy you know he was
in depth jam fighting for new york yeah
yeah so so it was crazy like and i was
with a bunch of homies and
and like
somehow i start fighting bro they start
trying to grab me and start fighting two
guys and [ __ ] there's some there's the
clip somewhere on instagram i remember
the clip that's why i asked yeah if you
were gonna say this but so i'm start
fighting these two guys right and then
like the clips on instagram there's like
me [ __ ]
dropping this guy and [ __ ]
and then yeah um there was that fight
[ __ ] happened right
somehow after they'll go over the fight
you punch them in the face
i'm gonna get to the location in the
face
yeah i'm fighting yeah punched in the
face but it gets i'm gonna give you the
punch that actually can't that i was
like i should have not done that okay
yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna get there
because i felt bad after i felt really
bad
all right so i felt bad after the fact
but i'll get there all right so we're
fighting whatever and deported or
something that guy no no
listen listen
the guy this is his friend i guess the
who was like yo don't take his chain you
just got it so he [ __ ] up for saying
that so my homies were like get that
full so bro we're like beating him up
he's like running from like literally
sunset to across the street to crazy
girls on like sunset on the board
exactly where he's so so he's running
towards the gas station on the mobile
across the street and we're beating him
up as he's running like doing the whole
trip the back of the cartoon yeah like
get up food and then we took a chain or
whatever
and hey hold on you took it no okay yeah
i don't think you should talk about
robbery
i didn't that just says r on it that's
his [ __ ]
[ __ ]
the guy's name was robert
[ __ ] you
so whatever like yo the change the chain
got took that's it and um
the chain got took
scared of [ __ ] i'm sorry yeah the chain
got took and uh whatever so we were like
yo we got a dip so we all dipped we all
[ __ ] went to the after party
bam bro we get to the after party as
soon as we [ __ ] park and we're like
about to go to the door
yeah after partying downtown
this is where i i kind of i was like
[ __ ] i should have not done that but it
happened whatever i was with uh the same
group of people and we went to this
after party we're already hot
everybody's hot i'm already hot because
i don't like fighting being mad
yeah everyone out there yeah yeah matt
because i i don't like fighting so when
i get to that level bro i become a
different person you know what i'm
saying i'm not even me no more like
racist i'm just ghetto ass fool now you
know like i'm the fool that you wanted
the whole time you know so
bro so yeah so now i'm on some evil [ __ ]
now anybody steps up to me or anything
i'm gonna [ __ ] knock them the [ __ ]
out type [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
bam we get to the after party
[ __ ] this guy is tripping the [ __ ]
out going crazy like who wants some who
wants some so in my head i'm like
i do
i was mad so i was just like bam i just
punched him like really bad bro and he
fell down and i just seen him leaking
did you see it coming
he was asking for bro
he was calling out the securities and
all the securities were like not trying
to [ __ ] jump them or nothing so
nobody was doing nothing and i was
already on some [ __ ] so i was like just
pressing those
boom
and then everybody started clapping for
me i felt bad and they like they were
like nah bro you gotta go you gotta like
the homies were like come on we gotta
leave like so we all got in the car and
booked it so he just stayed down yeah
and then like i just i don't know
nothing i don't know who it was i don't
i was just like [ __ ] it i'm yo i need to
go home before i do some dumb [ __ ] i was
on some wild [ __ ] but now that i'm
thinking about it like that that's the
punch that i'm like yeah [ __ ] my bad
like i don't know who it was
kid was 14.
if you're at an after party drunk as
[ __ ] trying to fight security guards
yeah get there
get out of here
nah get the [ __ ] out of here bro yeah so
i yeah that was the last one that i
remember that i was like [ __ ] i should
have not done that you know but i took
my ass home and i was like [ __ ] that i'm
going in um
i gotta go to sleep
yeah the demon had to go to sleep bro
so the video i saw it's this full
floating and overheading some full right
no he's like
god you see this is like a metal shirt
it just [ __ ] a metal shirt a metal
like metal and death metal oh sorry not
a metal
you actually could put armor on it
yeah i felt really bad too because
like someone told me like apparently
they do try to press charges to the
building and [ __ ] oh he woke up
no well no [ __ ] i was going to ask i
didn't want to ask our cameras in case
yeah yeah yeah no no no he got up he was
trying to press charges that security
beat him up and they were like that was
not security my man you stepped to the
wrong guy type [ __ ] you know
and it was one of those but i was like
[ __ ]
can you sue a venue if you get all crazy
to security and they knock you out well
they're all going to lie until you pull
the knife out that's never going to
that's never going to you ever see
walking tall you know it's so crazy that
that
that
[ __ ]
a week after we went to uh like the
prayers uh [ __ ] show i think i took
you guys to the prayer show yeah and one
of the security guards in the front was
like
you're the guy
like yo dude yeah come on in he died he
died no no [ __ ] no and then the sad part
is that he's telling his other homie
he's a security guard he's all like this
hey he's the guy that that i was telling
you about so i'm like yo bro don't tell
this tell everybody that it's me
security that i knocked one guy with one
punch and now you're telling this
[ __ ] you start lining them up yeah
bro the security guards look at me like
yeah i wonder if you could take me type
[ __ ] you know i'm like i'm like bro shut
the [ __ ] up you know like i'm not that
type of guy who's your favorite
technically but yeah but that's not i
don't want i'm not that dude i want that
energy in the first place yeah off
camera omar's a madness guys he always
punks everybody for stuff
no no but i'm not that type of guy so
when he was telling everybody like yo
those guys bro was on demon time bro
like yeah that was a different exception
yes yeah
i got a question for you oh what up
yo what's up guys just taking a moment
to talk about the sponsor of this
episode and that's our homies over at
expressvpn let's get right into it guys
go to expressvpn.com forward slash yola
when you use our code at checkout once
you subscribe that's gonna get you three
months extra for free expressvpn
essentially gives you a pathway to the
internet without anybody being able to
take your personal information my little
brother knows how to code he just turned
18. imagine what he could have done at
12 there's little hackers out there just
stealing people's information and
selling it on the black market that is
real it's not just in movies guys so
when you use expressvpn it automatically
protects your devices in your home and
your possession and honestly what i like
most about it because you guys know i am
not tech savvy it is super easy you log
in you get your stuff you press a button
you're protected there is no giving
numbers and downloading and talking to a
person and making sure everything's
connected and having someone come no
this technology stuff guys if i can do
this you can do this one last quick
example i just went to new york i had to
log into the hotel wi-fi i'm not going
to log into the hotel wi-fi unprotected
i have my youtube on there i have my
bank information on there so go to
expressvpn.com forward slash viola
that's going to give you three months
free on the year subscription don't let
hackers sell you personal information
it's out there guys it's real so
remember expressvpn will help
can you tell everybody about the time
you try to get a couch down your uh oh
[ __ ] yeah
dude
you tell your perspective up until
i got there and then i'll tell mike he
opens up the blunt he knows he needs it
it's the equivalent of austin powers
yeah yeah it's difficult as soon as you
said it i've i've been there i've been
there with the stone no you haven't okay
okay i did movies staircases
all right never saw this okay all right
here you go
so
i i wanted to move this couch out from
my room from my game room downstairs
upstairs to downstairs
i forgot who [ __ ] helped me put it up
there obviously it was him because he
helped me take it down and we'll get
there too
i couldn't take it down and up [ __ ]
uh
don't say it all yet the whole point is
i couldn't take it down down a staircase
down the staircase to the point that i
tried i was like [ __ ] i'm going to
give it a try push it and i'ma just have
[ __ ] jade spot me or something you
know big-ass culture like uh it was
it was it was enough for me to pick it
up type [ __ ] but like the i needed a
little help assistance you know like
just just
that one get over there just all the way
just to get over the bar type [ __ ] over
the round
yes i was like i think i got this it
can't go up because of the second floor
bro so toward the end of the staircase
there's a ceiling above it yeah somehow
i get the [ __ ] cow stuck between the
chairs i mean between the [ __ ] pole
and the stairs bro stuff stuck
and i made a hole in my wall hold on
hold on hold on before you keep going
i'm up
don't go all the way no i need to
yeah release this the right way and then
i went inside my room i took the couch i
was like [ __ ] i made a hole all right i
started pushing the couch back i pushed
the couch back
and then i called a friend i was like
hey
i need a tool
oh don't say it yeah okay okay i need a
tool
hey screwdriver
unscrew the wires
i need a tool okay so that i called a
friend i was like yeah i need a tool he
said for what i need to take this guy
down
he's like what the [ __ ]
they borrowed the stool
and then i [ __ ] it up
broke the tool and then did what called
who and then i called thomas
you ready thank you for not giving that
was a great explanation by the way
broke the tool no
that's his death broke the blade
not the tool yeah but apparently the
tool is broken and i replaced it okay
okay okay so ready he calls me and he's
facetimes me and goes hey i need help i
go
this couch and he shows me
and i just started dying and [ __ ]
laughing like no [ __ ] way this man
had tried to saw the couch in half
that's what broke up
it's not mortal kombat i tried it bro i
tried i tried to get a saw and go down
the hole
as if it was like a chainsaw yeah yeah
yeah
yeah but it was a circle
and i broke the blade he broke the blade
because it cut the material got caught
in it not done i went
you put holes in your wall there was
holes in this wall
big deep gashes where you just see
plastic still couldn't get the cop no i
looked down and go
you're going to be mad
go pick it up
low out we got it immediately out in two
seconds
oh the first time i tried to do this was
tetris yeah but i didn't i needed two
people in the first place yeah yeah yeah
um
yeah
yeah i had it it just it just had to
this was sacrificed the couch you lost
that the wall he didn't want the couch i
don't want the couch he was just trying
to get it out so he was like [ __ ] us
all in half gotcha he tried to saw it
i've [ __ ] been there before basically
yeah yeah it's crazy i don't know and
then said hold the couch as i throw it
off my balcony
don't hit the truck of the neighbor
through it immediately smacks the
[ __ ] neighbor's truck
it's the same balcony where you push the
same balcony
my meth
[Music]
oh man sorry that
oh and then what a month and a half ago
some guy hits you up like hey man should
i use my saw it's broken so omar just
had to buy this guy in new soul a couple
months ago and this was like two years
yeah
i didn't know i didn't know i didn't
know i just thought it was funny like a
couple months ago that guy hits him up
about like yo my [ __ ] song i'm like
did i break it really he's like yeah you
just did the [ __ ] out of that yeah
there's some type of stuff stuck in it
it was the material
and then i was like
yes the upholstery yeah looks like yo my
bad g like i i'll send the money and
then yeah
i was like yo i'll buy you one he's not
just just send me the money bro it's
cool and then yeah that's cool he got it
fixed shout out to my guy though he led
me back to the street it was funny
omar did it yeah yeah he saw the saw you
was like this [ __ ] [ __ ] but yeah
yeah i broke it i just thought it was
about bad bad i just thought it was
really funny dude
that's hilarious we used to he-man [ __ ]
off couches and [ __ ] off the top of the
u-haul truck onto that second floor
patio yeah yeah like that uh man i've
got some buffalo she's got an oven stuck
in the [ __ ] hallway trying to get him
up those little stairs and [ __ ]
i've been there bowling i'm taking
action
my question is i've taken action
hold up my question is though how do
people in new york put their furniture
up okay you ready i did a movie for so
long i didn't moving in oregon moving in
oregon has so many steps the second i
went to new york the first thing i
thought is
i'd hate to be a mover here
that's the first thing i thought
you just do it new york made me realize
that you don't need anything everything
is the 1800s yeah lift it
cook it walk
yeah
that's that's all of new york
that's it
i'm telling you dude you just lift it up
yeah i was thinking like people got
furniture that's a brown still there's
probably no elevator yeah yeah that
because in portland there's like three
four stair stories i've taken up
people's entire lives up like
that was one box
four minute trip
like it's depressing yeah bro imagine
like you live on like let's say you've
lived in projects or something
i understand how the first thing i think
of when i see people's houses like
that's crazy no i'm gonna move here i
would not move here [ __ ] that trying to
move
stealing your [ __ ] in between you going
up and down and
yeah right oh [ __ ]
you leaving boxing the third floor
anytime i moved in anywhere i'm eyeing
up the whole [ __ ]
yo you leave a box to hold the door on
the third floor the box is gone my
uncle's moving company my own cause
moving company my dad has moving company
my cousin adrian has moved yeah they
probably have bad backs huh no oh they
lift right oh okay
yeah no no but i'm saying like that's
our whole family so i never have to
worry i'm just gonna call my cousin like
yo come help me move over i'll pay you
yeah
not me
i hate moving dude let me be the first
time i get like some help and yeah yeah
because i've been moving everybody
else's [ __ ] my whole life yeah moving
sucks [ __ ] sucks but um
yeah he tried to cut a couch i tried to
cut the couch routine i could have
couched he punched a guy in the face
yeah did you fix the walls uh no no
no
there's still one hole in there come on
man that's the deposit right off yeah
take it off the depo take it off the
deposit fix it later yeah for sure yeah
just i could fix it though i could you
know bring my home depot skills
sometimes oh man i bet as horrible as
that would be april wishes i would do
some [ __ ] like that just for the [ __ ]
freak out what just those figures just
to be able to walk in there and see me
in that predicament like
the couch stuck and then you turn around
this whole staircase
is nine feet wide oh don't i've never
seen a stair it's like the staircases
that they walk down and then show their
daughters in the prom dresses
no it's just a wide it's a [ __ ]
titanic leonardo dicaprio white ass
there it looks like where beauty and the
beast come down
[Music]
you can fit seven people sitting
when you said that back in season one
you're like you could drive a truck up
that [ __ ] street probably every time
i look at it i'm like i could get it i
probably could get a truck up here
you never have to worry about moving
marty's [ __ ] slide [ __ ] down
[ __ ] drinking water you know you made
it yes
you know the stairs are [ __ ] nine
inches wide
here we go to get off of this topic and
get back onto it
music stuff real quick what up a lot of
music i hear a lot of people that try to
make music and a lot of people send me
music i think they hear a trend and try
to ride it but how does that
differentiate you from the person that's
most popular in that trend of music
um does that does that make sense to you
yeah yeah yeah yeah because it can only
be
uh one new zealand thank you
it doesn't mean that you can't sound and
do take some inspiration but some people
are going
how would they do it that's what and
they expect to [ __ ] make it see the
thing is
if it works for somebody it might not
work for you you know what i'm saying
that's the thing so it's like i wouldn't
see your shirt and go i'm going to do
everything just
blue yeah yeah yeah that that's the kind
of the comparison
so for example exactly there's this
artist right now that everyone is
listening to his name is yeet right
and ye has a certain sound that sound
that he brought up
with him
it's like uh
almost
spaceship sounds and like electro
weird
but it's trying to sound like that no no
no no no no no
all weird like all weird like like weird
sounds
but i never heard it's sick as [ __ ] not
but see now every other artist is trying
to rap with those same type of beats
trying to sound like him so it's like
bro just let him beat him you know is
that is that more of a label thing
they're like
well no it's because that's what
currently is popping but that's what i'm
saying like you ride trends hard yeah
they die what are you going to do
me personally i don't
i listen i
i look i could be inspired i could be
expired i'm aware but the thing is i
will never copy anyone
like that's one thing me i would i can
admire somebody's work and like it and
probably bump it because you'll never
say it because there's some there's
there's a couple people that look
and sound yeah i [ __ ] identical talk
to this [ __ ] yeah yeah or that's
hard to do because he's unique as [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying like
so you're saying
you made that [ __ ] coincidence all right
you never know maybe they just got the
same brain as you no but but the thing
is
sometimes
i know
you know it's crazy people have
uh like same wavelengths i don't know
this is like the waves the sounds you
know sometimes but sometimes sometimes
people can think almost the same but um
but not really you know what i'm totally
like i've experienced that even in like
graphic design yeah oh for sure just
kind of happen
for example i had this conversation with
uh with first i was going to say first
again
so first had this conversation with
sunny
and
travis travis scott and then they also
they
all three think alike
in different way forms but somehow when
they meet they're like they feel like
hmm did he copy me or did he do you hmm
because they're in the same wavelength
god no one's copying nobody mm-hmm
that's different they're all in the same
room no no no no no no no no
but when they meet up and they're like
they're hearing each other's [ __ ] we're
like wait a minute i thought of that too
and i did it too in another beast so
they're like this [ __ ] thinks
like me but in a good way do you know
what i'm saying because their big dogs
obviously they're thinking the same
almost like it's just a wave i guess a
wavelength for sure yes you know just
probably tapped in but like i said like
i was like i was trying to say earlier
when people when you when you
when that is you like yo that is that is
me now does that does that
does that make sense
like when people make music and
perfect example like in old movies in
the 90s yeah people would try to be like
jim morrison
yeah that's me bro they make music just
like it like bro you're never going to
be more than a cover band that way yeah
yeah but when it comes to rap it's so
much [ __ ] more active yeah yeah so
many people make so many different
styles bro there's so many different
styles but what i was saying like you're
saying the eat thing but now people are
trying to do he beats and he everything
but for the people out there maybe
there's people that make music out there
that
don't have their
you're not going into the studio and
going you know when i saw this guy
earlier let me let me do all that [ __ ]
and that would never happen there's a
reason why you're there only thing that
i would say that i would probably do is
put myself in the mood or like
for example
drugs you should try it right the travis
scott song big it whatever first made
that song okay
and
he would tell us
try to make yourself feel like you were
there again that time that same
that song that feeling try to make
yourself something like that that's
different you know what i'm saying you
could let's say for example
kanye
uh what's that father song or whatever
that yeah
whatever
try to make yourself feel that way and
make something but not rip it off you
know what i'm saying don't fall oh the
feeling it gives yourself the feeling
that's
that's why you're talking about being
inspired by this do that you can do that
that's what i meant all day you can do
that you can [ __ ]
get inspired by old [ __ ] or whatever it
is and take something from it but like
not
instruments no unless you're sampling
and chopping [ __ ] up that's different
that's way different there's open game
on that sense of originality you can
sense when somebody's really in there
yeah yeah shut off their chest versus
trying to be cool yeah because i do
reggaeton trap metal
80s uh cumbias
everything spoken words
everything you know what i'm saying so
it's like
i don't feel like i'm copying anyone you
know or
if someone would come out to be kind of
like me
then [ __ ] cool but hey man don't try to
make me sound like i'm a dick over here
i'm just you know what i mean
if i started off i started this whole
thing was off was hey there's some
people out there that dress exactly like
this oh well they
they can dress like me bro they know
that but they will never be me you
[ __ ] i'm saying they're it's an
example
as an example like this one made his own
sound like yeah yeah you know him too
right yeah yeah yeah
mm-hmm
yeah
yeah that always comes with the two oh
yeah yeah well that is that'll always
happen that would always happen
it's like it's like it's kind of like
um
in fashion fashion is the biggest
rip-off of everything yes they rip off
everything and i know like that like
they know like you know what they do i'm
gonna tell you the insides of fashion
they [ __ ] grab a clothes from the 90s
that they like if there's a tommy hill
figure whatever it is oh this [ __ ] used
to be popping back in the day let's
bring that [ __ ] back let me go look for
a [ __ ] jacket retro jacket
grab that jacket take it now [ __ ] put
my tags on there do it like this make me
this jacket that's fashion like this
that's [ __ ] strange designed me a
jacket i'm like no i took two pictures i
like this kind of cut of jacket i like
the way this jacket has these colors
yeah i like these kind of patches on
this jacket but i like this material
yeah blend it blend it and blend yeah
because
it's a form of stealing i guess it's it
is bro all if you really want to say
it's a former student bro all the brands
all brands because i do rip each other
off bro
that color is like
you know what i'm saying like you know
every brand rips each other off bro yeah
of course and it's like it's another
form of sampling i guess in music terms
it's a form of sampling
because you grab it as a sample the
[ __ ] product
shirt whatever you
and they just put your own swag on it
it's sampling it's the same art
form in [ __ ] fashion and music the
wave the current wave yeah
yeah yeah and then guess what if this
clothing brand is popping more than this
one everyone's going to try to copy this
[ __ ] brand well also fashion
their
color guide book that comes out you know
like toward the end of the year for the
next spring this will be the color next
that's how nike bases [ __ ] yeah yeah
right well that's basically like the top
100 charts like oh so these are the
things that work and maybe that's why
people try to emulate and try to
reproduce like okay that's a number two
hit we can just change our style a
little bit we could be a number two so i
get why people would alter their sound a
little bit to try to pop off but i'm
saying people that look at ours go
that's what that's that's what i'm gonna
that's my sound yeah that it won't it
won't it won't work yeah yeah or work
for a minute because it'll work for like
for a minute and like a little
you might get some money out of it you
might but
it might not it might not work on the
long run you know and the long run is
what matters i think because they're
gonna know that that is not you as a
real person or character you know what
i'm saying oh for sure and one of the
things in music or anything in life just
be you man just [ __ ] be you yeah
that's all that's man i've been going
through this all week start man going
back to my little notepad writing these
little bars and [ __ ] for the first time
just different person like yeah it was
really i was i didn't know how it was
going to be but everything we're saying
is just like the same [ __ ] like yeah
yeah i just tap right back into that
same little muscle and it was right
there like yeah this is you know it's
not like riding a bike but it's like i
was thinking about all that like i'm on
like we were saying last time like i'm
only going in to do for like my own
originality i'm not thinking about
nothing else aside from that with this
[ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah you haven't listened to anything
since you [ __ ] last recorded [ __ ]
that's true but but see
he doesn't know it's at the end of
movies
i listen to a lot of music right
but
the thing is with me i don't listen to
new music as crazy as that sounds i only
listen to it if it was brought to me or
put yeah yeah like yo i've been trying
to listen to new [ __ ] i've been on
discovery
like back then don't get me wrong when i
first started and i wanted to be the anr
i wanted to be the connector
the dot connector to everything i always
had to be put on game before i was
always that guy you know i was searching
like let me see who's popping in
jacksonville let me see who's popping
here so i would just check random spots
and find good talent but now i just
i guess i'm just too focused on trying
to create and make yeah actually
now
that i don't i don't focus on looking
for new talent or nothing like that no
more like
but if it comes around dude by any means
send me some [ __ ] if you guys are
[ __ ] some new producer you're
watching this that's what i'm saying
everything bro like
send it over bro like i know the people
i know yeah i might if you're fire i can
be like yo i'll send it to this anr be
like hey check this kid out like you
know what i'm saying not these comments
but you know him what's your instagram
so you not in these comments yeah yeah
yeah what is your instagram so my name
is rachetton and
r a t
c
h e t o you don't have to i'm just
kidding we can pop it up on the screen
i got a spanish music question here for
you yeah yeah say it in spanish say it
in a spanish how do you feel about ricky
martin up against 50 [ __ ] stop stop
stop stop stop stop stop stop we're
going to get we're in trouble stop we're
getting trouble no we're in trouble we
can't talk about that stuff marty oh no
every time we do we get horribly age
restricted yeah yeah rosie episode we
talked about maybe prison versions of
this
okay okay okay let's end this let's send
this like this he's just living in the
local oh my god shut up
shut up
oh god
[Laughter]
jesus christ i like it that was great
all right you know
yo man we can't talk about current
events on this goddamn show no home
we we can
whenever we're treated like everyone
else so we sign this deal we do our
thing yeah we're treated like everyone
else you know it's crazy uh all i gotta
say is
so i don't know someone said it
no no no i said
someone
don't
just said it that it was all they're
just accusing him yeah let's leave it
alone but i don't know i don't know i
don't know i don't know yeah
yeah i don't know i don't know so five
weeks i can't speak on it for three
weeks in a row man uh-huh that's true
it's sad but true sad but true and
people i know like you're sensing
yourself now yeah yeah shut up how about
that how about that how about you you
talk talk to youtube for us yeah and
tell them like hey they're their whole
show we're we're in the process of
working it out so we don't have to dance
exactly we're doing something right now
so we don't have to go oh should we talk
about that no i'm gonna start
horrible things
talk about [ __ ]
1944
world events we'll talk about whatever
we want
all right let's leave it at that for
history buffs
or if you stayed awake and we're trying
we you know what i mean we try to tap
into the current event i know what
you're talking about let's not yeah you
know what's gonna happen you have the
best soccer theme song hey let's just
let's literally dance around this okay
i said this
okay
okay
can i hear some sound effects can i hear
something that means um
how come you don't continue to smoke all
of your joint or blunt at once because i
like to i just gotta smoke do whatever
you want like
chill i don't like to get [ __ ]
you do all the time i mean i do but
every day i take my time today for just
like
important
i'm sorry to me if you're a man that
says i only smoke backwoods like that's
me says i'm somebody that's i'm a real
i'm a real weed small grassy yeah yeah
hold on hold on you got it backwards if
you got it back backwards backwards you
got it backwards you got it backwards
because back would cover up the smell
the taste of disgusting weed oh really
hold on but okay did you smoke
if you smoke bammer and paper you could
taste it you smoke bammer in a backwood
it'll mask it slightly because of the
tobacco and it'll be thick you have you
have agreed with me on this topic many
times you see you got any [ __ ] it's in a
backwood anyway you have said that
before so i'll fight him right i say
this right oh i say yo do you have any
any
any cheap weed stop
this guy doesn't have cheap weed who why
would he have cheap weed
it doesn't matter
cheap weed to him is like amazing no i
don't care i don't care what you say
i don't care exactly but you agree with
it shut up in the comments you can leave
it in the comment if you wanna fight
i've never seen you you wanna i will say
i've never seen weed exist in your
sphere that wouldn't be worthy of a
joint at least yeah so it's like every
time i was like yo do you have cheap
please like this
backwards anyway yeah
my name is
thomas sorry i switched to
and today we have a ratchet tone he's
coming in with the mexicans uh talking
about mexican music and a lot of
particular how are you doing
uh hola hola migos see
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you smoke backwards i'm not saying
you smoke trash no saying you can cover
trash you could in a back one it's like
a see-through bag versus black
background
if you get honey berries or some [ __ ]
like that like like the actual i get
plain i get like original i don't get no
flavor
that's the difference
have you ever played tekken yeah you
know martial law when he used to run up
the knee run up the chest kick and then
land yeah i'm about to do that to you
right now yeah yeah marty go for it
marty it's happening thank you
it's happening that's cold right holy
[ __ ]
water's better cold what the [ __ ] were
we talking about
we were talking about how you said that
backwoods suck
i hate tobacco but two eats do your
thing you smoke hell about he every
three months he goes i'm gonna stop
smoking backwards man i spent like
[ __ ] four or five hundred dollars on
backwoods which is the dumbest [ __ ] i've
ever heard when he made bombs and
produced his own bongs
i did it for like a week yeah a week he
did it like i'm saving and then i did
like on twitch i did the twitch thing i
was taking dabs which i don't take dabs
but lately i ain't gonna lie i've been
like on the discord you know what i'm
saying talking some [ __ ] with the guys
they're like dab up they're like you're
not damn fool you're not i'm like all
right fool i'll be showing them and
she'll be like the little oh [ __ ] he's
gonna take a dab they'll be tripping out
because i don't dab you know and when i
do i'm like
dying and [ __ ] but i said take ball
right now yeah dabs are a different
story
yo you gotta start smoking more bong
rips
you'll save a lot of money your lungs
will thank you
how many backwoods are you going through
a day realistically
um i don't know wait they're peds who am
i hanging out with normal day at home
like two a weeks average no [ __ ] no we
can't do it normal normal day
going to the studio
not going to school not going to go to
the studio every day
sometimes he doesn't yeah sometimes like
on the weekends sometimes i'd be staying
in some of them um like today today yeah
okay today today was one of those days
it was one of those things he's
sponsored by fred durst really don't
um
[Music]
so
average in the day i would say probably
like three blunts
yeah it's like an eighth wait how much
you put in a blunt no i could roll
decent blunts i don't i don't like
graham one point like one point one okay
like but i know how to roll them to like
to the point where it doesn't taste like
[ __ ] one more prison rolls up but not
like
if a prisoner had like a ball and budget
i just learned like not only
but like like look look decent he wasn't
like
joint sex yeah but see rapper blunts are
they're eights though they're like these
and they look like [ __ ] opening up in
one spot yeah yeah so no i i smoke
like you know decent yeah yeah no i'm
saying he lets him go out
yeah
he always does i was just talking [ __ ]
to him yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
just to do that like when you see me
when i was recording i said yeah yeah
yeah because i don't yeah yeah i got it
too
like that's what i like to do it's a
[ __ ] program do you normally get the
same type of weed like when you go by
weed yeah yeah i got i've been getting
weed from my guy for like say his name
and address say his telephone number
actually this guy this guy look trip the
[ __ ] out though this guy
shout out to my guy no he's been working
in the industry for he used to cook for
madonna okay this guy's old
guy hole just out of them super old just
got kicked in very specific very
specific his ethnicity and his old job
oh
damn nah nah nah is he's he's been past
that he's legal for sure like
so he he just broke he has a business
and [ __ ]
drops off to all the celebrities bro
every celebrity
this man is the [ __ ]
so
so you're on his run of celebrities what
you're saying no
i used to work for him long time ago
okay no he has a shot bro it's chill
okay
that wasn't actually
he knew he has a shot all right michael
jackson's sister michael jackson didn't
come over my house to use the bathroom
yeah yeah
but you know what i'm saying like he has
all the celebrities pull up to the
[ __ ] shop oh they just mean he's
dropping sacks no he just said it drops
off sex well i mean he drops off to me
yeah
he's my friend
oh but i i think he's dropping a
madonna's house i'm sorry let me
no a lot of famous people go to buy weed
off on monday she sells to james oh no
this address no
[ __ ] idiot
so
yeah we we have it so good bro i i can't
stop were you smoking weed heavy as a
kid like in your mouth house oh yeah
actually my mom caught me smoking weed
everything like i've
she like cause you're not hitting the
face with shoes yeah she [ __ ] you up
no no no actually like it was actually
funny because she didn't care good
question i never asked him she yeah yeah
she didn't care that i smoked weed but
like she just hated it that i always
boxed it you know what i'm saying you're
a [ __ ] dick and i had little stuff
what's up rockers
bro i used to jam out in my room loud
like literally like what like behold
you're saying what's up rockers
on the on the screen go watch this great
movie yeah yeah well yeah bro like i
what's up rockers like those the homies
played for the opening two sacrificer
like thrash band they went to lock to
that same [ __ ] high school like one
of the homies actually is in the [ __ ]
movie like shout out to my guys in south
central i grew up going to south central
like playing with the band and [ __ ] so
my mom used to [ __ ] just get mad at
the fact that we used to get drunk in my
room everything bro it was like my mom
was cool as [ __ ] like she didn't care
bro like she would tell me i'd rather
have you in the room do it there than be
out in the streets like posted up and
trying to [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying yeah you get caught slipping and
all that [ __ ] so it's like
do it in the [ __ ] room just don't go
like you know what i'm saying and then
obviously i don't know
i i don't know if you had this but i had
an old van that it didn't it wasn't
drivable and we just go in there and
smoke
yeah yeah so it was coming
yeah so it was like one of those like it
was my mom's first car
and then she gave it to me and then this
[ __ ] didn't work no more but it was just
sitting there so we would go in there
sometimes i would find [ __ ] homies
that would ditch high school and they
would [ __ ] i would wake up and then i
would hear like
that someone's in my [ __ ] car and
then
it was it was the homie he was dead
she's like yo i don't want to wake you
up for you want to smoke like get up and
i'll be like [ __ ] if we jump in the
window so they jump in my window i let
them jump in the windows [ __ ] and bro
everybody used to pop up in my room just
jump in the window like [ __ ] it let's
smoke like yeah that sounds like the
most dangerous [ __ ] i ever heard it was
crazy bro luckily i always leave my
window open so my friends just come in
the whole night you're scared
bro luckily luckily like that was my
house bro
my house was a [ __ ] you can literally
jump out or jump back in bro i would
wake up and pools would be like knocking
out my window like yo
yo yo yo like a three or some [ __ ] or
we'll be all up and then they'll be like
this one time
neighborhood friend right
we used to we call them crackalacka you
know say or or we used to call him
shower time because we're like because
we wanted him to shower or whatever
because we used to see him on the block
and they used to call me sperm
rockers
but this is funny this is funny so this
one day right uh shout out to the homie
though he uh [ __ ] we didn't want him
to come and kick it and we're all
kicking it in the [ __ ] house and um
we didn't want him to come and kick it
because we're like bro he's not gonna
want to leave yeah yeah yeah he's not
going to want to leave and and also bro
like sometimes he will come dirty
because he'll be in the streets all day
like white tea all nasty and dirty
you know some crazy [ __ ] right people
don't out of state might not realize
hollywood is grimy as [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah it is bright it's dirty as
[ __ ] [ __ ] grimy grimy so
uh so he we're like no we don't want him
to kick it bro so let's pretend that
we're all gone because we're like you
know having to sleep over not really
we're all [ __ ] smoking and kicking it
and drinking or drinking king cobras at
the time oh [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying a few things i can't yeah yeah so
we were on some ghetto [ __ ] right so
then he's like yo what's up he pulls up
in the window hey fool hey let me let me
come in and kkk fool now we're like nah
bro i'm about to go to sleep
i'm about to crash you know like the
evils are about to leave and he's like
oh for real i'm like yeah yeah he's all
right therefore i'm gonna just be uh on
the next building after like he's like
all right four i'ma see you and then i
pretended to close the [ __ ] window
whatever everything turned off the
lights and then
ten minutes later it was obviously we're
smoking getting boxed i opened the
window and we're all laughing and [ __ ]
and then we hear the door slam
from the other building across the
street
um are you a [ __ ]
swear to god bro we all started dying
with our emotions
and it was because we didn't want to
help you to come in but i just heard
that we just go slam the door
but yeah man that [ __ ] window was
legendary i'm not a [ __ ] box
legendary
i thought some [ __ ] was gonna happen no
no it was just funny
he just yelled like oh are you a [ __ ]
like fools getting chased [ __ ]
helicopters they're hopping in another
building going upstairs to the roof
like fools are hopping everywhere like
i see somebody get shot in the butt like
all kinds of [ __ ] shot in the bed yeah
because he was running him
in the butt yeah
bro it was crazy
i see people getting chased i've seen
helicopters i've seen people jumping
jumping
fences running for people
someone gets shot in the bus
daytime
it was crazy
i got a good question i was thinking
that we could ask the guests
in times like this
who's your craziest neighbor you ever
had
uh
the craziest [ __ ] a neighbor ever did
growing up in the apartments and [ __ ]
well this that guy the guy that i'm
telling that dude was him he was my
neighbor that that my mom didn't want me
to hang out with you wasn't your age no
he was older than me
oh i thought this whole time he was your
age going to school oh hell no he was
always older than me this homie that was
already doing the and [ __ ] and all that
he's older than me and he grew up in
that building i know that guy you know
what i'm saying and like oh
yeah so it's like a cigarette he's got a
cigarette or like for example we would
play baseball and he would break some
windows and [ __ ] and then we would have
it was always him you know
like real baseball like you like but
yeah baseball oh he missed smoking no no
we'll play baseball and [ __ ] or he'll
throw a ball or something he'd get mad
and break a [ __ ] window he's slow
like no hell no how much older was he he
was like
um
he's more than five years older than he
has insane yeah like he's probably like
four years older than me like but but he
but
he was just a wild one bro like he would
go out and get drunk get [ __ ] up
you'll see him in the streets [ __ ] up
you know what i'm saying like but he's
the homie and [ __ ] so he wouldn't never
trip when you see him in the streets but
he'll be drunk
he has that voice to watch like
yeah yeah
why [ __ ] yeah yeah like and then like
that's my boy you know what i'm saying
like he but he you know he finally he
had kids he changed i mean
yeah yeah no he drinks once in a while i
mean i see him on sometime you go visit
his mom with his kids and [ __ ] yeah he's
changed he's not the same no more so
i'll show you in a box that's all i got
from the whole store's like she's just
trying no no no that that's that's the
hub
that was the job yeah yeah your master
lives over there like where you grew up
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah she it's too good
to to leave bro she had rent control bro
yes bro we've been there so long only 14
dollars from a month bro she has a she
has what
i have no idea she has a three bedroom
apartment in [ __ ] hollywood for a
thousand bucks or a thousand one hundred
with a parking spot everything that's
insane why the [ __ ] would you want to
leave like you know what i'm saying like
she's you know in china you know what
i'm saying but i got no religion either
but but like she's been looking she's
like i'm i'm trying to buy a house now
and she fixed her house in el salvador
so she's like i'm gonna go back to el
salvador as soon as these [ __ ] girls
are like my sisters are [ __ ] that age
then they can take care of themselves
you know what i'm saying so yeah my
mom's looking into the future right now
to like get a house and my uncle just
bought one on riverside i think so it's
like there she i guess he's trying to
help her get a house or i don't know
what the [ __ ] but
yeah so did you grow up going to el
salvador oh yeah yeah i was there before
kobet actually hit and um i got here
literally the week before the close of
borders or else i would have been stuck
in el salvador i've been tight i would
have been stuck in el salvador for a
year and a half sourdough vlogs
that would have been insane because i
didn't have my computer or nothing i
didn't have [ __ ] let me see that would
have been i'm kidding oh actually no i
had my iphone so i could have done it
was it like city like did they have
apple stores and [ __ ] there or not i
mean the cities man bro i was i was
i was in a ranch
i was in the ranch they were building
the first [ __ ] walmart type [ __ ] like
south park i just watched that episode
yesterday the walmart they're fixing it
and [ __ ] but like i'm pretty sure it
costs more you know what i'm saying like
um real quick
one time
one time
this guy
on his twitch
[ __ ] up and was like yo i'm gonna do a
subathon so basically every time someone
subscribed to his channel
he would have to stay on
live for another 30 minutes
what a dumb decision it should have been
10 minutes
dumb decision
what happens if someone drops a bunch of
subs on you what happens if someone
named thomas is like yo watch this
what happened right when he was almost
done what are you doing
it happened you were so happy
it made me so excited dude knowing that
like he you know
you know it's crazy too like
then obviously shout out to the [ __ ]
smitty committee like smitty is an uh
post malone's dj and tour guide he goes
on the tour with him so i play a lot of
video games with him and [ __ ] we play
online and
he was streaming too he was streaming so
he had his community there so i guess
somebody was watching my stream and went
on his stream too before like i guess
thomas was already asleep i had 10 hours
left for like no
four hours four hours left i was already
like yes [ __ ] yeah i'm hitting there
bro somebody went from my chat to his
chat and said ratchet only got three
hours left
and everybody's like yo yo yo
everybody's like yo yo ratchet only got
three hours left
so boom he's like yo let's go to ratchet
stream he goes and goes to my stream and
he's like [ __ ] that boom boom then he's
like yo everybody in the chat go [ __ ]
drop us up on ratchet
bro i'm wait i'm like falling asleep and
i hear bing bing bing ding ding ding i'm
like
[Laughter]
no
no
and it's him like just
like kind of like slizzard because he's
been drinking online he's like
dying laughing
like ah
i was like yo
got some dicks but see that's my fault
because i didn't know how to run the
timer thing i don't know so stupid and
then so every time i got stuff it was
like 30 minutes why would you dedicate
a half hour forever i dropped 30 subs on
the guy yeah at least how did you do
that you just sat there i did
dude i put a [ __ ] pillow on the floor
too i was like yo [ __ ] it i'll put the
camera on but i'll turn off the mic just
say cameron
no no no camera um
i thought i left the camera on and
i was i was [ __ ] sleeping i turned
off the mic but i i don't know one time
i did forget to turn it off you can hear
me kind of like
they said there were people just in
there there were just people in there
talking [ __ ] watching them sleep all
kinds of [ __ ] how long did this go on
for
45 hours three days almost two days hold
on but you cheated me you cheated me you
had extra hours you know i had two hours
no he never did them though no i know so
he cheated me i did go in the next day
and did too
yeah i did hasn't made it for you no
that was two hours no the doubles though
if it's not in the same stream right now
it actually quadruples every day shut
the [ __ ] up it's like a [ __ ] lady
yeah dude it was one of those well i was
like there was times where i was like
[ __ ] should i just [ __ ] give up and
be a [ __ ] and i was like nah i was
texting him on the side by you ready and
then just go down his eyes i was like
nah i'm gonna do this [ __ ] i ain't
stopping me now i'm [ __ ] going
um
[Music]
yeah that was kind of cool but i wasn't
prepared
yes you were you just shut up i did it
[ __ ] up
she just said 10 minutes
huh for everyone out there that means he
has to sit on live in front of his
camera on his twitch account every time
someone drops a sub he you probably got
over like 200 subs
yeah yeah yeah it was it was bad it got
bad it got real bad um
i'm about to smoke these blunts and mark
you guys
it's saturday it's saturday night
and um marty you've got one day to edit
this [ __ ] video so we're not going to
go three hours today really the last
time
yeah one day
so right here let's smoke these morning
i got one for you
uh omar i got one for you this is
the video i just did on the dopaziola
channel this is the superb blunt
this is two and a half it's two grams
and on the outside
is dusted crushed up diamonds that you
would dab
it does look like straight cocaine
smoke that dusted diamond
not dustin diamond screech an r.i.p
[ __ ] in my life man i never i never
smoked you like that in my life i never
um
here we go
oh let's try this [ __ ] dude there you go
oh [ __ ] oh man i've been seeing the
macros of these things oh my god
salivating over this [ __ ] yo
there you go this [ __ ] looks like
cocaine
yo real quick yeah just watch the thor
movie
dog [ __ ]
don't waste your time
sorry i just had to throw that out there
real quick
i want to start doing movie reviews or
something yeah just like that
second video this movie [ __ ] suck
most movies like it's either that or i'm
gonna sit there and
[Music]
stop it stop it that's from a movie
movie poop shoot dot com jay and silent
bob yes sir yeah
i had to reach for that and i just saw a
kiosk
so you grew up basically listening to
metal yeah right
well
no i grew up listening to everything hip
hop
hip-hop
whatever i say yeah whatever you say i
grew up listening to hip hop rap and my
my kids
my dad now
my dad was the guy that only listened to
oldies only oldies right did the side
step a lot uh
i guess i don't know you know what i'm
saying
no
the old school i was thinking what's his
name frog
from [ __ ] uh colors remember when he
started dancing at the bonfire that's
how i imagined it right now like wasn't
the oldest yeah yeah no so yeah so my
dad was uh the od guy
my mom was actually the
she listened to everything like nirvana
[ __ ] ace and bass guns and roses
uh ice cube
like she would listen to all kinds of
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
and
my uncle was a strictly
hip-hop
dr dre snoop
uh cyprusil
all the other [ __ ] you know i'm saying
all the like the gangster [ __ ] right
so
i got all of those and my grandma i
would wake up every morning to listen to
spanish music like the classic stuff and
all the the cumbias and all the other
stuff that was all my grandma
i have all of that you know what i'm
saying growing up but in high school i
chose metal music because
i'm i'm a fan of the dark art i guess in
black metal and death metal [ __ ]
i am bro i'm a fan of the dark arts no
he means dark art bro because dark arts
not like yeah yeah yeah not like [ __ ]
witchcraft you gotta explain it better
because that's what what the [ __ ] what
did i bring up in other words in other
words i liked
dark music
death metal black metal thrash [ __ ]
all yeah horror movie [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know like
[ __ ] that people be like oh what the
[ __ ] are you listening to and i'm over
here jamming out the cannibal course
you know what i'm saying so
but
that's why when i make music now i can
hit different
i would say melodies that other people
can't because i heard it in black metal
or i heard it in in in a death metal not
even like
or a power metal song or whatever iron
maiden metal like you know what i'm
saying you can relate to so many
different people so i can use different
chords now when i'm making
for example if i wanted to remix which i
wouldn't because metallica would come
for your ass if i wanted to remakes one
then in and then
you could do that you know what i'm
saying and right just
just get the one note you know like one
note of each yeah but like bro it's it's
crazy i don't know i guess i use metal
music too to produce with
new
trap [ __ ] because it sounds evil you
know what i'm saying trap music sounds
evil so i can relate to it i can make
some evil keyboards because yeah i'm i'm
thinking black metal but he's thinking
trap you know what i'm saying so when we
do that mix it bro it's crazy
like cleveland cardi's doing that right
now you know what i'm saying he's
putting his track he made a trap album
now he plays with a guitar crazy guitar
no no he has somebody playing with him
live in the guitar bro it sounds insane
bro i swear if you look it up right now
he looks like a [ __ ] vampire coming
out and i i saw i saw i said it was like
a [ __ ] no bro like it's actually it
sounds
i was paying attention you know i was
like i was like holy [ __ ] dude okay i
see you bro likes it up you're mixing
trap with rock now and making it more
energetic like you know what i'm saying
like the song
i forgot what it what what song is it
bro but the song comes in like with pure
bass and then the guitar
just like small you're like oh really oh
[ __ ] yeah
check check out how cardi performs now
it's so crazy so now i'm seeing it like
oh [ __ ] cool i i could [ __ ] do that
easy you know what i'm saying so here
comes first yo do some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] but now he comes him and adds his
effects or whatever and it sounds
you know whatever the [ __ ] it is and now
i'm making different sounds and [ __ ]
like metal with trap
that is crazy i don't know i i just hit
different waves right yeah and speaking
of music this week you went and did
because last week we talked about it how
you're gonna do your music oh yeah yeah
shout out and then oh yeah shout out to
tom for making that happen and then he
went out there and did his [ __ ] [ __ ]
bubbling i'm sorry i know it's just
distracting me like yeah this thing is
bubbly yeah so marty came over to the
studio
and um [ __ ] lay some [ __ ] down man
yeah man first time in eight years crack
that [ __ ] seal
dust off crank that voice
i lost my voice yeah after the first one
yeah for the last one i think it was the
last yeah we tried to do two tracks i
lost my voice it's different
it's like a muscle i got to get it back
but
man i've been i've been in my zone ever
since that really that i was like oh
yeah i'm
convinced
i was trying to remember the lyrics but
something about i've been certified
before it's funny i thought about that i
thought about that this morning right
there terrified before
and as i was driving to jay's son's
birthday party i thought of that as long
as i hit the the 14 off the fire i'm
like yeah
yeah that's funny that's the first thing
i thought about damn i was like okay mr
punchline over here far from bars
no it's funny like i used to have so
much other different direction in my
mind going into songs but now it's just
like it's weird like i don't i don't i i
couldn't sit here and do this forever
like i have a very specific
type of [ __ ] i want to get off my chest
right now it's just nice it looks like
it was it was dope it was dope this is a
great little chapter yeah yeah it's
different like being in the studio
recording is just different yeah we kind
of just fell full circle yeah
well inspiration mood board you made
with a certain picture
oh crazy
that
explain
yeah they don't know
when you when he told me this that
really gave me the [ __ ] chills
because even like so
when we i put together multiple mood
boards to design moodboard marty yeah
yeah for sure yeah when we first went to
the set design mood boards yeah they're
necessary though
they're a
professional part of the design process
yeah yeah so yeah we were i was putting
together mood boards to decide the look
of the set and i used the example from
this studio yeah on the mood board
like blue neon
all this [ __ ]
because it was nipsy hustle studio yeah
yeah yeah and it's you know my all-time
favorite rapper and [ __ ] and this was
his studio i like i there's this crazy
story that i i mean like we were in that
studio right this is how the angels work
like
these two random dudes pull up to the
studio but the hawaiian guy is like yo
brad what up you know he knew them like
i don't know from instagram or whatever
but he said what's up to them so we're
like oh he knows him cool like
but we did none of us even first was
like i don't know who are they you know
but he had a trumpet he pull out but
they they [ __ ] bro the guy had a trumpet
another guy had to he brought his own
keyboard he set up he was like ready to
play
and um
we're all looking like
okay cool like they're setting up
they're ready they're ready to [ __ ] i
guess so first it's like all right let's
cook some [ __ ] up so first starts
cooking some [ __ ] up the guy's playing
the trumpet [ __ ] sick we're like what
the [ __ ] they make a banger like
[Music]
like a [ __ ] anthem type of [ __ ] right
and then he's like yeah bro and then
like i guess first was like what the
[ __ ] like who are these guys tripping
out like the only guy that knew was the
hawaiian dude though yeah yeah so first
i was like wait they were tripping out
wait wait wait wait we got into the
bonus yeah
building into the into the room walked
in and said what's up to everybody we're
like oh what up what up but we were but
we were like but you guys didn't let him
in no no no no this is a very secure
that's why i want to ask like so they
just walked yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
they had i guess they had a password and
everything so i was like wait what the
[ __ ] type [ __ ]
cool we're gonna get there um so we're
we're like tripping out they're making a
[ __ ] banger they made a banger and
then first it's like i guess he was like
tripping in his own head he was like i'm
gonna ask him and he was like yo bro i
don't even mean mean i know we just made
a banger but wait you made a whole song
before he asked yeah yeah he's like who
who are you he's like
oh um
nips bro or or one of his people him to
know i don't know if it was him or
somebody in his cab
send them to go to the studio
right but they thought that
that was his whole so they pulled up
they went in there they set up to make
music but they were like they were just
there to make music but oh damn he's
like i think we're at a wrong studio
then
and we're like yo that was nip sending
them right here bro to like make a
banger quick
the dudes did it that was i guess nips
is or something like that and like oh
yeah
actually passed away it's not just
yeah yeah so yeah so it was like it was
like they got it
yeah i was like whoa that's crazy so
it's like wow the man sent them and they
made a banger bro [ __ ] banger but
first wasn't tripping like he was just
like yo and he's like oh [ __ ] i'm at a
wrong studio i'm not
he's like oh [ __ ] but it was it was cool
we're like
that's [ __ ] dope bro we're like
that was [ __ ] awesome yeah what are
the odds right and then the hawaiian guy
the homie [ __ ] brax is like
yo i mean i knew him but i didn't know
if you know that's what you do
my bad is that this is brax holy [ __ ]
wait brax doesn't do nothing we talked
about it's legal hey
wait no no no wait i'm not talking about
no [ __ ] drugs i'm talking about a
musician
hawaiian guy i said two hawaiian guys
you did
yeah they kind of went to the desert yes
holy [ __ ] that was this episode
what the [ __ ] dude
where are you right hey man i'm here but
[ __ ] two different wine dudes in the
same
hour okay i got mixed up sorry you only
smoked four half blunts
finished one of these [ __ ] yet
because you keep feeding me these
[ __ ] crackhead blunts those three of
them cracking bloods they're fire i know
but look at all this you'll be okay you
haven't even touched no i did bro
everyone's driving right now everyone's
driving right now there's kids in africa
that would eat that right now
basically is what they would say in the
50s i eat my vegetables that's not true
you eat raising canes ain't nothing like
that
no i don't remember you [ __ ] me up so
they popped in they did the stuff oh
yeah so they popped in they made a
banger and they ended up finding out
they were at the wrong studio but they
got hit up through their people to go to
the studio and yeah it was that was cool
it was amazing but trippy it was cool it
was dope
yeah that lets you know that that's like
i mean the top quality like that would
have been like when he was like going to
make his album like i'm going to build
he had money at that point i'm going to
build this make sure it's perfect i
could tell when i walked in there like
oh this is the top flight studio in here
top flight studio in the world chris
is dope and legit and you're in your
little habitat in there at the boards
just looks so natural like that's so
sick that you can go in there and just
create and be a part of that yeah ma i
mean shout out to first man like
we'll be on the show soon yeah yeah he's
gonna he'll be here soon um
if if like he has a studio and he has
two rooms and he literally says yo the b
room is for my friends i give you the
password go in there use that [ __ ] make
some bangers go in there don't [ __ ]
around but
[ __ ] utilize that [ __ ] while i have
it like [ __ ] you know like
it's amazing that he can let let us go
in there and [ __ ] use thousands of
dollars of equipment and just go in
there you know obviously clean after
yourself but bro yeah that's a blessing
just to be able to do that so many
people would love to be in that position
ready
top five rappers right now
right now that you that that because you
do
know of artists i'm not going to listen
to everything who are the top five
rappers right now that i like or that
that are up right now yes you see that
are up that you think are going to be
around for a long time top five rappers
that are gonna last that are making
music um
you don't have to exclude [ __ ]
top three then damn that's that's kind
of it's a hard question but you make
music [ __ ] ponder light a blunt
sip of a beard
[ __ ] dude
you put me on the spot you're gonna
interview me yeah
i mean
[ __ ] dude i don't know
i don't know it's a great answer i don't
i don't that's funny no bro because uh i
listen to so like i said i don't listen
to any music [ __ ] so you say
more artists but but i i do i do like um
right now i would say the people that
i'm listening to i would say is valley
or valley
you talking about the uh
got a kind of soft voice
that one from pittsburgh or some [ __ ] no
no no
about uh uh uh uh the he has a song
shell
valley
valley
[Music]
skinny dude
this shit's tight yeah he has a song
with drams that's really hard yeah i
like his trap [ __ ] this [ __ ] is sick
justin boy justin boyd showed me him
with uh chase the money my boy chase the
money he
him him them two together
this shit's hard i really [ __ ] with that
[ __ ] with him he's i mentioned his ass
before like in season one actually i
mentioned that dude i was like you know
who i've been stuck on lately and it was
that full yeah a video got recommended
to me that you like from i think his
name is russell something like that
oh okay okay so i'm sure what's up i saw
some [ __ ] on tick tock no i don't be
it's crazy like i don't be tapping in i
should be but uh
you're in the music industry i know but
the thing is
i'm not tapping in because like i i
don't know i'm so busy with what i'm
doing at least listen to me no no no no
no i'll listen i'll pay attention and
i'll hear it i'll yeah you're not gonna
hear
no i just yeah yeah of course i haven't
i haven't been like i haven't been
searching lately because i just been on
the zone and creating of course that i
haven't been searching so i kind of but
it's i'm not a dude i saw a tick tock
that had he had like some agape [ __ ]
yeah he was in front of he built the
whole theater in his backyard oh is that
what it was that's what it was he said
hey build me a theater i really [ __ ]
with i love that he just set his shop in
his backyard [ __ ] made me laugh
and it was tight yeah bro and then
somebody keeps suggesting him they keep
suggesting in the comments and i looked
at him like it's the same [ __ ] i
just liked on tick tock
yeah yeah yeah i've been held dms about
this [ __ ] dude apparently from the
bay oh okay it's kind of hard man yeah
he was wrapping his ass off it's kind of
hard i liked it a lot there's yeah bro
like you know what's crazy though
tick tock shows me more talented people
that i just oh for sure i love my outfit
it's insane how like tick tock bro like
there is so many [ __ ] talented people
in tik tok and like
that they're probably just
remixing like old songs into their own
versions for fun just for tick-tock to
the point that people are like yo what
what is that song i want to hear it you
know what i'm saying like or
they become popular because they're
covering songs in their own way or bro
like for example
i met this dude recently his name is
connor he [ __ ] does beats like little
loops on tick tock he'll be like
yo this is an idea steal this
like use this [ __ ] i've seen that
whatever and then
he'll be like yo here's the stems
download them if you want to bob
bro that dude is [ __ ] killing it
right now and like shout outs
like and like it's a thing where you
interact with the another talented it's
like a split screen yeah yeah you
respond to their video yeah and do your
music
yeah
i watch a lot of ridiculous things and i
see a lot of talents
no definitely tic tac has a lot of
talented people bro i see a lot of
people making beats out of nothing of
like
some random dude like with a with a
string or like yeah i'm over here yeah
oh yeah that'll be whatever yeah prison
give me a pencil
hey we're not in [ __ ]
top five like movies of all time oh
thank you thank you for checking these
out has a bad taste in movies that's
what i'm trying to do no no okay number
one my number one
uh wedding wedding singer i love you oh
it's your favorite movie yeah maybe i'll
take it back a little bit that's my
favorite movie it's a great singer it's
great amazing self-taught no lessons
and confused oh okay detroit rock city
oh my god you have a [ __ ] thing uh
wait
go
are you flirting with me right now you
have a thing
for certain movies keep going
[ __ ] um
what else documentary kiss the sand lot
[ __ ] so you saw everything when
before you were 16 basically i i like
bro i mean i i used to be my mom used to
somehow give me all my grandma actually
because she used to get kick downs from
like old the the old fat tapes the hell
yeah covers and [ __ ]
so bro i had a grip
my grandma used to clean some like
ladies crib in beverly hills and i used
to go as a kid i remember i used to be
like yeah i used to live in beverly
hills when i was a kid i was like a
stupid kid
but i was just kidding
yeah but yo that would give me all the
kick downs bro and it was amazing like i
i i remember that like it was crazy but
um i had all the movies so i s i saw a
lot of movies but like city of [ __ ]
god um that's yeah that's that's a
somewhat there's like 15 years old
that's that's not oh yeah hello you're
talking about classics no i'm saying
like i'm not i'm talking [ __ ]
i'm saying you like detroit rock city
days confused but those are
i've never seen these movies are you
[ __ ] serious no
you're a dad though you're a dad you
don't have time to watch what random
[ __ ] no way do you i would have these
are movies i would have watched before i
was stabbed right
sure for sure sure
so these are all free and do that this
is me not watching movies bro
what
all right all right i can make you a
wild lip it looks like this
yeah that should be that i'll make you a
[ __ ] list yo bro
if you watch some of these movies i'm
sorry
detroit rock city city of god which is
great but i think it's in spanish um no
it's some portuguese portuguese it's a
great [ __ ] movie bro um
what else [ __ ] there's a lot of movies
bro i just
how to be a player
that's a great movie bro
i like i used to like [ __ ] watching
the wash and [ __ ] like little movies
like that like
bro obviously friday i know every
[ __ ] word in that movie you know i'm
saying literally i can
tell you the whole movie and [ __ ] like
is that your favorite la based movie
what friday think about this uh all
those classes no no no no no no no no no
my favorite would be obviously menace to
society you know what i'm saying like
growing up my society in south central
drinking a juice in the hood poison what
no he tried that he's like no
yeah
i'm smoking
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that was some oh gee [ __ ] did i tell you
what you did to me
but i think i i think i did tell you did
i tell you the pocket i don't even know
you [ __ ] i'm talking to og i ask him a
question he starts explaining the answer
to me
uh thomas how'd you cut a lawnmower just
say that that's what it is an emoji so
thomas what you're going to want to do
is get the lawnmower and as you're
pushing it you turn it on and you're
going to pre huh
that's what he did to him he was
explaining something to me and as he's
sweating he loses me goes home
like he wasn't just explaining
the whole [ __ ] answer that's a good
shirt right there it was a that's a bad
brain poop
oh
he looked at me
it's like it's like a spirit leftist ass
and then he went huh and he just came
back yeah so he goes there that's not
ghost dad
yeah hey man we might even get in
trouble talking about bill cosby movies
out here sorry youtube yeah but no i i
i'm still getting flagged i liked a lot
of [ __ ] movies growing up like that's
cool like the good ones like for sure of
course we all think our movies will be
no no i mean but i talked [ __ ] about his
movie taste because he told me uncut
gems was trash
even though he he's he's trash okay
great great i just know i i don't know i
just didn't like it it was i don't know
it's adam sandler's uh dramatic role
that made me do this
any reaction other than this movie
[ __ ] sucks
it means the movie is doing its job how
do you say it you have any songs i just
said he called me with jade and said
this movie [ __ ] sucks
that's a reaction i will fight you
i was doing quarantine i was on my couch
before i got my new couches i remember
pictures is it just because it's adam
sandler exactly he [ __ ] loves adams
get off the [ __ ]
it was a great movie
sometimes they phone in like denzel i
love denzel no
20 years worth of [ __ ] phones but it
put it this way
if you watch it you wouldn't check your
phone
and that's when you know like all these
movies got me locked in bad
for me it was because it was like it was
basically continuous the whole time i'm
sitting there [ __ ] just
[ __ ] this just anxious the whole time
and that means all right they thought
about these scenes and that's the
reaction i'm trying to get okay that's
all i'm saying in terms of watching it
put it out again
yeah put it out again i [ __ ] smoke in
in in sessions hey it's okay man these
[ __ ] rice crispies i've never had
seen a thing like this before this
wasn't rice crazy look how many [ __ ]
soldiers are in there just waiting to be
smoked
there's like five i wish
i want you guys to go on omar's
instagram bikes finish your blunts full
what do you mean hey man you're broke
this one broke all right so um
what time were you at what
150 no we were just at 130. yeah we were
150 oh my god we talked about this stuff
just yep everything no the first episode
we haven't touched on forrest gump in a
[ __ ] water i was just about to say
forrest gump something and i brought it
back i was like you know what thomas
just stop even though i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm just trying this new thing
where is god where where i'm trying to
stop doing things out of habit
as i light her
i didn't really watch forrest guard are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me have you ever
seen it more than once uh yeah but i
don't know
watch oh yeah that's a good question no
i haven't seen it more than ten years
whoa you should watch it it's probably
one of the best [ __ ] acting
performances watch it again it's great
to watch movies twice
do i really want to watch four's gone
[ __ ] no yeah i just say i oh
you might want to go back and watch that
one i feel like you're missing something
you're [ __ ] why because you could
appreciate a [ __ ] cinematic
masterpiece i mean i i i like it i saw
it more than twice but i'm just saying i
don't remember it right now then because
it's been a minute if you watch it then
you'll be like oh yeah you should
remember this ah and then i might turn
it off
because i'm going to remember
omar's going to be the pigeon lady home
alone for halloween
omar is also going to put on a black cap
shave his beard shorten his hair and
play the mom the scary vertelli vitelli
lady from [ __ ] goonies oh he's going
to play the mom that don't bathroom on
the right oh my gosh she's on the right
she has like a cangle hat or [ __ ]
or you can just dye your hair a little
bit and
you'll be sam kenneth
oh you play a lot of characters here
i could you could play a lot of
characters here i want to do like some
[ __ ] casting for bro i tried actually
one time i probably didn't tell you this
but you're in the system of a down video
no no no i [ __ ] try to go um
that's dying as [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh yeah so one day they were like
yo you want to try for commercial [ __ ]
right and i was like
all right what are we doing he said i
don't know just go see like go try out
go
they're going to give you a script and
say that [ __ ] a couple of times spread
your butt
[Laughter]
yo
yo
pause
so it was a sneaker commercial and i
didn't [ __ ] i was like oh [ __ ] there
were so many people trying out and [ __ ]
i was so nervous bro
that i i was just
i don't know bro i could i couldn't do
it i like i went in there i did the
words and [ __ ]
but i don't know bro i just i knew
they were not going to pick me bro there
were so many [ __ ] skinny pretty
people next to me bro
no [ __ ] i tried bro i tried bro i was
even trying to be all like
oh something about like yeah grab a
snicker like i was like over here like
trying to be oh snickers yeah yeah
no
i'm sorry my uh spanglish sucks
but yeah bro
then i was like [ __ ] i know i [ __ ] up
because i
i was like i don't know bro i couldn't i
sucked i know i sucked and like i said
brother snickers there was a lot of
pretty people bro and i was like yeah
these people are like legit there was
this girl outside like
like trying to get doing this [ __ ] over
snickers like you had a chance centering
herself yeah bro like i was like damn
i look at myself and now i'm looking at
everybody i'm like i'm not gonna get
this [ __ ] conversation why you didn't
get it uh you have to speak into
existence no no
i was going with the hopes of i'ma nail
this [ __ ]
but no bro that was very anti-christian
of you oh no no no when i
you're [ __ ] happy this is blasphemy
yeah it was
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah but uh
yeah so pretty much
that
you got to start featuring
your tick-tock feet or something [ __ ]
yellow pics
what yo look at that you're talking
about a [ __ ] tic-tac video right now
right
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
oh i'm just talking about that gun in
general
i'm sorry but that that tick-tock
i thought was one of the funniest times
in my [ __ ] life the other day sorry
man that
that
but nah man what's that good just
[ __ ] hard bro
zelda
all of them that [ __ ] is hard that's
that that [ __ ] reminds me of like old
hip-hop like crazy old
in metal no no no no that [ __ ] makes me
kidding actually makes me want to go
tagging type of [ __ ] like oh for sure
makes you want to pull the [ __ ] ski
mask down yeah
yeah that's the energy you get from it
don't you worry about that
when i used to like listen to old like
[ __ ] hip-hop and [ __ ] like wu-tang
growing up listening to like
all those type [ __ ] even like isis into
like
jedi mind tricks and [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
and
um that [ __ ] made me want to go like do
graffiti for some reason now i don't
know it was just that feeling that just
like fired up like
even like deltron and [ __ ] deltron
thirty thirties oh yeah yeah yeah
favorite albums
it's like [ __ ] dude like that [ __ ]
and then like you i would grow up and
see like la like uh [ __ ] videos where
they they like tagged yeah the whole
[ __ ] yeah bro those were amazing
like bump bro are you shooting up over
here
with like the whole like remember like
vine doesn't like the tick tock and you
mean you're over seven years old one
[ __ ] it was eight years ago
no no like bump fights is like almost
like the the bum fights like crazy back
in the day you know what i'm saying you
write my name man
that's wrong my name i i remember i used
to see bing bling like on fairfax
i don't know
you never seen bling bling crack pipe
hitting the side inside his collar bro
he knows crazy though i went up to him
and he's like don't call me bring bang i
don't know who that bling bang is like
he was cracked out there yeah of course
but
you should have said that to him
but that's the thing i think paramedics
should be just getting
right there of course it doesn't make it
copy written it would no it was on the
board yeah was it just for when i put on
the new ones it got just just for fun
just press it one time yeah this is for
you it's like
early season too they were i was kind of
overdoing it what the [ __ ] oh who cares
who cares
oh good job you're almost done with the
[ __ ]
drug part
maybe you should put some like mortar
combat sounds or like humpty [ __ ]
that's actually me for everyone out
there didn't i that's my sound i know
you pop up like this huh
that's actually me yeah yeah yeah
yeah every game pretty much
so uh wrap it up
all right cool to wrap it up when are
you going to do this twitch [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] are you going to play
what are we doing like two days already
sent me my stuff i'm ready to go oh okay
so we're ready to go
uh what are we doing now we uh twitch go
follow they let me change my name it's
dope ziola with underscores in between
it's not dope you'll efficiently but
somebody used to have it so they let me
change it finally
w for the chat yo it's been over two
hours
this was about to speed racer edit
okay hey guys
marty and i
would like to thank you for being here
and that was all that was awesome
hello guys exactly i would like to
say how do you say thomas thomas is
super cool in spanish
that's not what it is
yeah i know you guys heard it no it's
not yeah that's not that it is i know
i know enough spanish to know that that
is not i mean thomas is super cool
okay that means something about a dick
no like you're like it's a it's a way
that like you're tight
oh there's no way we can not we have to
wrap it up now that was perfect that was
[ __ ] perfect
holy [ __ ]
all right two hours for two hours in all
right cool cool you're almost done with
one blunt [ __ ] with that that's cool
boom boom boom boom boom
i appreciate it
uh marty you got anything you want to
say
feeling good guys end of season too
things are wrapping up you're almost not
kidless
yeah yeah i've been just locked out like
a [ __ ] psychopath since my family's
officially done
thank you for all the support on this
music [ __ ] though we put that post up
man the reaction we got from that was
crazy yeah i can't wait till you drop
that
really made me want to do it so thank
you guys it's about to be amazing when
you hear that man can't wait for that
hell yeah thank you sir i love how we're
doing this this is how i used to do it
in buffalo used to like it's a little
like self-serving thing where we kind of
help each other out to get [ __ ] done
hell yeah yeah let's get it
we got and i'll smoke joints
i rolled a joint like uh two days ago
and it was from uh paper it was pretty
cool it was like i don't know i liked it
and i rolled it kind of like a blunt
yeah
but but but i'm sure they get tutorials
on youtube
i'm sure
[Music]
i can teach you in five minutes but you
know
and that's what his excuses oh well
so you can [ __ ] buy 36 backwards
i don't have papers no more oh i don't
have papers in my warehouse i'm not
stacked on an industrial level
industrial level can i have some more
cheaply
[ __ ] you
come on man i'm a rapper time man i
didn't get to go get backwards man even
though postmates exists he's all i
couldn't get him man oh my god i'll get
you backwards so if you saw me post the
backwards
they're for him i get there this 15
minutes in
this piece of [ __ ] goes hey man you got
any nugs
so we'll have me bring back woods
and then ask me for some [ __ ]
nuggets yo it's like that moocher video
that you made remember yes
i use your own video on you
i'll [ __ ] fight you how do people
find you on youtube
uh you can find me at ratchathon spell
it r-a-t i'm just kidding you don't have
to pop it up on the screen bastard
instagram what's your instagram uh the
save
same thing no this one's l e
do you have twitter uh twitter el rats
it's on do you use it daily you're
[ __ ] up i know you oh actually no
twitter is ratchet on just itself oh
start using twitter twitter's uncensored
no but twitter
oh there's so much porno there bro don't
look at that porno people [ __ ] repost
[ __ ] don't follow the people that repost
[ __ ]
it's red stop
by the fault it's giving them all the
ratchet
two button clicks
but there's be a lot of [ __ ] porno in
there
like that and oh there's porto you
should use twitter because twitter would
help your following because your
following is on twitter and twitter is
very music oriented there's a lot of
hashtags that actually work they don't
sense you like instagram
damn
is that god [ __ ] you
hey use twitter man all right yeah
that's like your advice voice like god
voice trying to yeah i wouldn't do
that sir you're [ __ ] fat oh
no i'm your conscience
that's a good one yeah that's right no
no no i guess i'll start using it more i
haven't yeah so that's how everybody
finds you yep that's it all right how
can everybody find you in person like
beat the [ __ ] is your window stay open
at your new house oh yeah yeah yeah
definitely yeah cool so anytime on
twitch jump in
jumping lane next to him yeah
with your hair coming out the side i can
finally do it look at the camera and
everything you look like leprechaun in
the hood
[Music]
i'm a leprechaun that's this
[ __ ] right here
that's it that's all i wanted that's why
leprechaun needed uh backwoods of
nugs yeah
hey come over can you bring backwards
can you bring weed how are you leaving
hi
yo and by the way i didn't beg you i was
just like hey can you bring me back that
was at work it was no i wish i had to go
no you didn't say please you went oh
come on man i'm on rapper time man and
then you were like i got these
cheeseburgers man oh damn oh [ __ ]
damn i did say you got your
cheeseburgers
of course you do every time no i don't
yes you do
i got these cheeseburgers man [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you say it
i don't give a [ __ ] if you need to wear
[ __ ] i was funny but bring back
you know where that line is from
yes i'm just [ __ ] her of course
that's him though
that's him now
he'll be outside raising change like
yeah
his hand tattooed you guys didn't know
that hand tattoo on the left that's me
before i even met him this guy's [ __ ]
flirty with me that's me wrap this [ __ ]
up
you look like you stopped the
all [ __ ] i got about 15 minutes
left um
uh
what do you want to talk about 15 no 14
minutes left go
14 minutes left i'm kidding mario got
anything else to say
let's see what that hat's about one time
my hat oh yeah come on so i can rob omar
afternoon oh
[ __ ]
you look like the hood leprechaun right
now yeah you look like the hood
leprechaun
hey man i like it that looks like it
could have been out of the corner store
or it could be expensive as [ __ ] out of
like a designer luxury store four
dollars okay that looks like could give
you a rash if you start sweating in that
[ __ ] boom boom boom
you're still being multi-use here we go
what'd you say dopest is ugly i say
you're still hugging me i'll [ __ ] box
you
it's okay though all right everybody can
find him there at certain parts of
social media if he ever wants to post
he's on twitch on spot oh yeah on
spotify too oh yeah spotify oh yeah yeah
everywhere you need a manager
yeah you can probably be on spotify
he's
all right thank you for being here this
mask is
slightly itching my eye
see i told you i told you
no i didn't see there you go
eyes are itchy it's the dude that tried
it on before but i just touched my eyes
yeah oh see look oh he's been hurt
hey man
thanks for being here marty yeah thanks
for being here wretched guy
appreciate it
thanks all right guys this has been the
dovah's usual podcast my name is thomas
dobasil whatever you want to call me
today we have talked about a bunch of
[ __ ] mainly usually we talk about
life drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between i'm squinting
because my eyes are on fire
they're gonna start swelling they hurt
look like [ __ ] run right now
like ran from red and stimpy oh no
that's not a good look
oh red
do you like flock of seagulls
no but i can tell you do
that's your favorite movie
oh jesus is your favorite movie a call
back at the end of the show and this
will give me no expressions
wanna drinks water
i'm a [ __ ] kid man deserves a fiji
break here i'm dying here i'm [ __ ]
dying my eyes just caught on fire
i'm [ __ ] dying here go watch
reservoir dogs too by the way thank you
guys so much for being here we
appreciate it from uh ratchet man
register and marty and i my isaac have a
dope ass day oh my [ __ ] god my eyes
peace
it's like dante's inferno i told you i'm
gonna get a rash ah
these are judge weed
oh my eyes actually hurt
oh
[Music]